[Música]
el alcalde de nueva york bill de blasio
y el alcalde electo erika a dausá
anunciaron que desde el 3 de enero se
duplicarán las pruebas de kobe 19 a
estudiantes y personal de las escuelas
con testeo casero gratuito para mantener
la educación presencial un anuncio que
llega cuando en el país aumenta la
hospitalización de menores de edad por
el virus
chino acusó a eeuu de ignorar los
tratados del espacio exterior exponiendo
a los astronautas al peligro la estación
espacial del gigante asiático se vio
obligada a medidas evasivas para evitar
la colisión con satélites lanzados por
el programa starling de los que tenemos
análisis
y la corte suprema de rusia ordenó
liquidar el grupo de derechos humanos en
memorial la organización formada por
disidentes de la unión soviética
documentaba crímenes de la era
estalinista y la represión de los
críticos del presidente vladimir putin
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y estas son las noticias de france
24 el alcalde de nueva york bill de
blasio anunció que a partir del 3 de
enero día de regreso a clases se
duplicarán las pruebas de pcr de kobe 19
en todas las escuelas los tres test eran
para estudiantes vacunados y no
vacunados y podrían realizarse desde
casa en los últimos diez días se ha
producido un incremento de
hospitalizaciones de adolescentes a
nivel nacional
[Música]
ellos pueden aprender mejor cuando están
en un entorno en personas por eso es una
responsabilidad de la ciudad una
responsabilidad nuestra mantener las
escuelas seguras y abiertas nosotros
fuimos testigos del ataque y el
terrorismo durante el 9/11 y estamos
viendo cómo una vez más nueva york está
mostrando al país cómo liderar con la
crisis el gobierno es terrorismo pero ha
traído terror y la única forma de
combatirlo y detener nuestra ciudad
abierta nuevamente es que trabajemos
unidos y yo estoy listo para hacerlo el
hambre discurso el 2021 se aproxima a su
fin en medio de un repunte de contagios
de kobe 19 que según estadísticas de la
universidad de johns hopkins alcanza una
cifra de más de 281 millones de casos
globalmente siendo eeuu el país más
afectado por la pandemia en los cinco
continentes la altamente contagiosa
variante omicron obliga a las
autoridades a agilizar medidas
rafael pérez nos cuenta más
tras dos años de pandemia las cifras no
dan tregua en eeuu las hospitalizaciones
pediátricas se dispararon un 35 por
ciento con un promedio diario de 262
admisiones de jóvenes pacientes y la
semana previa a la navidad los números
rojos se concentran en new jersey nueva
york puerto rico y las islas vírgenes
esto mientras 52 millones de
estadounidenses han dado positivo en lo
que va de la pandemia y aunque rusia
registró una tendencia a la baja el
resto del mundo corre otra suerte en
españa' los medios de prensa destacan
cifras récord por primera vez se
registran más de 1000 infecciones por
cada 100.000 habitantes las pruebas
caseras gratuitas proporcionadas por el
gobierno regional de madrid escasean
una caja 2 4 6 8 10 20
y hay una cola esperando de 30 personas
australia marcó este martes un nuevo
récord de contagios
11.264 nuevos casos superando el pico de
la jornada anterior mientras en la
ciudad china de xian con 13 millones de
habitantes empezó una cuarentena
estricta tras registrar el brote más
importante del año
además de las restricciones de
actividades públicas y privadas que se
han dado mundialmente como en alemania
otras iniciativas menos convencionales
también marcan el segundo año de la
pandemia en sudáfrica los trabajadores
funerarios de soweto salieron a las
calles para promover la vacunación white
feather a la anda chica en porque una
funeraria se está embarcando en decirle
a la gente que se vacune no sería bueno
que la gente falleciera en el corte
inglés' en realidad no es bueno cuando
vemos vidas pareciendo así que eso es
parte de nuestra iniciativa hoy con más
de 5 millones de muertes registradas
mundialmente a causa del cobi las
autoridades insisten en que la manera
más efectiva de enfrentar la pandemia es
la vacunación en todo el planeta ya se
han administrado más de 9 mil millones
de dosis
en china el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores dijo que eeuu ignoró sus
obligaciones bajo tratados sobre el
espacio exterior exponiendo a los chico
nautas al peligro el portavoz de ese
origen dijo en rueda de prensa que la
estación espacial china se vio obligada
a tomar medidas evasivas para evitar la
colisión con los satélites lanzados hoy
por él olmos que en el marco de su
programa de starling los aparatos se
tuvieron dos encuentros cercanos con la
estación el 1 de julio y el 21 de
octubre según un documento presentado
por china a principios de mes a la
agencia espaciales de la onu vamos al
análisis con diego bakú director del
planetario de la universidad nacional de
la plata y astrónomo de la facultad de
ciencias astronómicas y geofísicas diego
gracias usted qué opina de las
acusaciones de china estuvo en peligro
la estación de los tico nautas
hola ángel es un placer si realmente
como bien comentaban en la introducción
a la nota hubo dos encuentros bastantes
cercanos por cierto el primero de julio
y el 21 de octubre el primer ocurrió uno
de los satélites de la constelación
starling pasó a 10 kilómetros
aproximadamente de distancia de la
estación espacial china distancia que es
muy cercana teniendo en cuenta que hay
personas adentro los taikonautas pero el
del del pasado 21 de octubre si lo tengo
aquí anotado pasó a escasos tres
kilómetros eso es extremadamente
cercano y no se puede correr semejante
riesgo porque ante una posible condición
de un satélite de este tipo estable en
con estación espacial si no hubiese sido
una catástrofe realmente esto está
chequeado está comprobado por distintas
fuentes por lo tanto creo que en este
caso las
las quejas por parte del gobierno chino
son más que fundadas bueno y entretanto
hablaron de los tratados espaciales como
está regulado el uso del espacio
entendiendo además que china es uno de
los mayores productores de basura
espacial del mundo
exactamente como como bien decís es una
de las potencias que está enviando cada
vez más material al espacio hay un
tratado tiene un nombre muy extenso pero
básicamente lo podríamos calificar como
el tratado de uso pacífico del espacio a
partir del cual desde mitad del siglo
pasado con el inicio de la carrera
espacial distintas naciones y potencias
se han
acogido a dicho tratado del problema que
radica acá es como muchas veces sabemos
una cuestión es la formalidad de formar
parte de ese tratado y otra cosa es
cumplirlo y déjame contar que todas las
potencias están de alguna manera no
cumpliendo con ese tratado ante
distintas acciones como por ejemplo la
destrucción
exprofeso de satélites para probar
distintas tecnologías más allá de el
envío constante de material a la órbita
baja terrestre es una situación que
realmente está complejizando mucho sobre
todo lo que son las misiones tripuladas
porque ponen en riesgo justamente la
vida de los astros
diego back de la universidad nacional de
la plata gracias a usted por el análisis
y seguimos con más noticias en rúsia la
corte suprema- disolvió memoria la que
hasta ahora era la mayor organización de
defensa de los derechos humanos y
memoria histórica del país el tribunal
alegó que había incumplido la ley al no
registrarse como un grupo extranjero
aunque desde el organismo aseguraron que
se trató de una decisión política amplia
en el siguiente informe álvaro cordero
es un golpe contra la mayor organización
de derechos humanos de rusia la corte
suprema de este país decidió disolver
memorial
y el tribunal falla para satisfacer la
solicitud administrativa y judicial del
fiscal general de rusia y así disolver
la organización no gubernamental
internacional de la sociedad histórica
educativa benéfica y de derechos humanos
memoria
la fiscalía acusó a memorial de violar
la ley que requería que ser registrada
como un grupo extranjero a pesar de ser
una organización completamente rusa un
fallo que generó protestas en las
puertas del tribunal supremo- memorial
surgió al final de la unión soviética
para documentar los crímenes del
estalinismo
pero desde 2015 han sido tildados de
agentes extranjeros especialmente desde
que comenzaron a denunciar algunas de
las prácticas del gobierno de vladímir
putin como impedir sus investigaciones
sobre ellos han caído acusaciones de
supuestamente defender extremistas y de
distorsionar la realidad histórica de la
unión soviética algo que niegan
memorial es solamente una organización
con su propia ideología está dicho
combinamos actividades relevantes de
derechos humanos con estudios de la
trayectoria histórica de rusia en el
siglo 20
pero parece que esto no agrada a alguien
en el liderazgo ruso
desde memorial sostienen que esta
decisión es totalmente política y que se
trata de un movimiento más del kremlin
para acorralar a toda la oposición que
existe hacia vladimir putin
y fueron arrestados dos aliados del
opositor ruso encarcelado al exceden
aval ni podrían enfrentar cargos de
extremismo los detenidos o son ex jefes
de la sede electoral provincial en las
ciudades de tomsk e irkus últimos
afectados en eventos calificados de
persecución de vladimir putin contra sus
críticos
siguen france24 buena tarde
[Música]